.
Why?
Let's go, let's go, let's go.
Let's go, let's go.
Keep it up, keep it up.
Step, step, step.
.
Thank you.
Out of bounds.
.
Let's go, Colin.
Ready to reach your peak performance?
The St. James Performance Club, located in Bethesda and Springfield.
.
My heart is over there, older than the trees, younger than the mountains, growing like a green country road. Take me home to the place I belong.
Blessed be God, my mama, take me home country road.
All my memories gather round her, mind is lazy, stranger to blue water.
Dark and dusty, painted on gold.
Light out, diseased, it's the road to shine.
What's up, Jack?
Get in that water!
Conversation, talking with Fletch.
I had to see him after that.
He was sitting on that side.
Luckily, he didn't come out.
My water!
One, two, three!
Woo!
Child, what is that?
Dude, look who scored.
Maya scored.
Who?
Is that your boy?
He did this when he scored.
I just saw, I got that on video.
Oh, my God.
What did he get?
Mission Security Solutions is a proud partner of Old Glory.
You know what that shit means, Tyrus.
Bro, Mission.
They're big.
Two ads.
Mission Security Solutions to schools, higher education, and the commercial sector in the DMV area.
I'm going to make that my celebration now.
Installed.
No, it's the crowd.
You have to be crowdy.
Access control.
Mask notification,